okay so remember what was the main
problem that s times good come now the
balance for the what we call the
determinant of complexity permanence
missions next day so remember it will do
minimum size of determinant in metrics
in a partner expression in the entries
of metrics deter units gives you back
from the main conjecture this is not
valid by any polynomial
today I want to give you an idea or a
bad idea of here to be a program that
has been annotated by Emily and solution
hopefully with a lab found new valves
and these Tom Nuttall complexities and
program has not been successful yet
let's say but please did initiative lots
of the interesting mathematics I
thinking that's when the idea is ever
right so it's really worth and thinking
more about it so the strategy is again
trying to involve as much as possible
and you break geometry and
representation theory and try to use
these as a tools that we know can be
efficient in some situations and let's
try to reformulate the problem slightly
so what we want to do is so again why
the permanent it's a m4m n by n matrices
as a determinant of a matrix of size n
which is a fine in the entries of of X
ok so maybe first remark is that can get
rid of this affine transformation you
can make it simply linear yes as we make
till in Europe I mean we have
if the IJ entry of MTX is something like
something linear a precedent constant
this is what is a fly map it just add a
new variable Y and we plug it inside
expression to make it linear okay then
what's the result of that when we
compute the determinant of this new
matrix okay now this is a result that
will be homogeneous of degree n
okay because we have a linear matrix and
we know that if y equals 1 we get the
permanent which is a modulus of degree M
so the only possibility is that we have
when we do this operation the permanent
x some power of Y which makes it
Virginia's of the relevant degrees why
is just another indeterminant extrane
determinant ok so I yes not a matrix
just just one when I stri determine it
okay so we have this expression so we so
we have not exactly the permanent but
this expression which is you can call
the padded prominent and maybe I will
denote it from an upgraded to degree
ok
so just a little trick to work with a
homogeneous polynomials which would be
better so then we look at the
determinant and at em so that's a
polynomial in the entries of the matrix
of size n so we have n square entries ok
but I edit one so i will consider this
as the polynomial in n square plus one
entries Jason this is a notation for the
space of polynomials of degree n in M
square plus one entry and now what what
am i doing when I apply the
transformation T ok so I'm just making a
change of variables a linear change of
variables so i'm using here the action
of the the linear group in n square plus
1 variables ok which one i will denote
by g ok
sailaja looking simply at the
determinant with that the orbit of the
determinant under the action of this
group yes but I so I see it as a
polynomial so the determinant does not
involve this new in the terminal still I
can consider it is a polynomial in one
more variable ok and now what what I
want to do is express this padded
permanent as something which is the
result of the deceleration okay so
something and dissolve it okay so this
is the question yeah so it's not exactly
the question because there is no reason
for this transformation T to be
invertible actually just a matrix so it
could be a singular okay but of course
I'm the group G is a an open subset of
the set of matrices so in fact what you
are you have something like this a
permanent for sure will be in the
closure of the orbit okay so question is
maybe whether on this one
okay so certain just some you sure yeah
because we don't exactly know what is
disclosure but what do we need to add to
do is to get the closure yes so for from
what this one the question is it just is
does the very permanent okay
it was whatever I was pointing here so
if you could use my am the original
question is indeed that the permanent
does it belong to this this place so
determinant transformed by some inner
transformation and if you want to look
this look at this question using a [ __ ]
break geometry it's better to go to the
closure ok so my observation is that
this is contained in the closure ok what
it is somewhere in between you don't
know precisely you know it is not the
closure I don't know exactly what are
the differences but so the question I
will consider is whether this one coming
when is the padded permanent inside the
closure the whole bit of the determinant
ok and so equivalently we can apply also
the group G to repair it permanent and
look at the whole bit
I take the cure so the question becomes
essentially this one we have 20 bit
closures and to undo the action in this
group and the question is as the orbit
closure of the prominent of the padded
permanent is it contained inside the
orbit closure of the determinant okay so
why is it better to reformulate the TWiT
this way because we have we can you now
algebraic geometry we have these
closures are affine algebraic right we
can use tool from the hydra by geometry
and we have this group so we can use
there are many tools in group actions
and representation theory okay so no
weapons to attack the problem
so so what can we do now so in general
we have to so this is in this big space
here khalid vm okay so we have two
algebraic some varieties of this space
and we would like to distinguish them
are they are they separated array is one
containing yet so there's a what could
we do the most obvious thing with it
would be to say that if this is not true
so if we don't have this inclusion so
what it is so this these varieties that
are defined by the set of polynomials
advantage and then the polynomial
equations so if we do not have this
inclusion swim in that we have when you
can find a polynomial which vanishes on
this one but does not vanish on this ok
so can we find so we should be able to
find so polynomial P vanishing
and this but not and you're great at the
pad it permanent okay so where is the
interesting problem to understand the
equations and the orbital to determinate
so much about this question but this
could be strategy so so the strategy
that we try to use will be slightly
different so what we want to do is we'll
use the fact that we have this group
action and we varieties really want to
understand there are closures of
something we really do understand
because it is just the action given by
the action of a group on the points this
this is what we understand best and
that's what we like to use so the other
strategy will be to look at functions
and these orbits resolve explosions
so here I have to explain a little bit
what can happen there are some
subtleties here and what what our
functions on an algebraic writing and
you have to understand this too will you
understand the problem so we have the
notion of the case we'd say you know
fine I'll be very busy but an affine
algebraic variety you can see as I said
as a set of zeros defined by the zeros
of some polynomials okay fine algebra
gray should be why it can be realized as
as I risky close the subset of Sun fine
space V as I get why the energy given by
set of solutions of some finite
collections of poly numbers
okay the point being that Prairie there
are many ways to take your preferred
financial break right and embedded in
some fine space and find some polynomial
equations which defined what you can so
what you can look at is the space of
polynomials so this is the notations for
over the field of complex numbers
polynomials and V and you can restrict
them to the functions I call regular
functions on why okay
so this is a subjective map and the
point is that this subject here which a
prayer is defined in terms of V so in
terms of the embedding does not depend
on the image so this is completely
intrinsic okay so so we have these
regular functions on life means that we
can represent them as restrictions of
polynomials and V and if you have
another embedding we will have other
ways to represent them as a regular
functions on another space
so this is the case of a finite you
break voice that I remote more general
algebraic varieties how'd you break
around is so essentially there are
writers which you can think of them as
being locally a fine varieties see
algebraic variety means that it has
covering by the fine open subsets and
then you can define regular functions
they are just those functions on Z which
are regular exactly in this meaning when
you restrict to this open subset
okay which means that they are just
polynomials so you have to have your you
variety and his regular functions are
polynomials when you restrict them to
some open subset and embed this open
subset in some find space so the point
is that you can have some this will be
important in this discussion but you can
have an affine algebraic variety but you
see it as an algebraic oh right and you
really don't see it as being defined by
polynomial equations so it's clear
example is a tech why go see Star inside
and I see so you take the fine line you
just forget one point so this is so this
is not defined like linear equations of
course so it doesn't look like a fine
but it isn't a fine variety because you
can look at it incites see to as the
space of them has been defined by the
equation XY equals 1 okay there is a
movie
and you see that in this situation so
what are the regular functions on why so
we can just take any polynomial in x and
y and restrict it to two why we will get
older the regular functions if you try
to do this from the first picture this
will not work because we have the server
where the coordinate Z Z here I can look
at the function 1 over Z it's an
algebraic function on why is not a
polynomial of course if you look at it
as a as a restriction and unsee to step
it up from C to you whenever x equals y
which is a polynomial so in this picture
you don't see all the regular function
as restrictions of polynomial functions
on your space so that's an important
issue
okay and that's exactly one of the
problem we will meet in a second hard to
say okay great
so now where you can remark is that can
use this subjectivity property if we we
know that on a closed subset of V every
regular function is the restriction of a
polynomial suppose that so suppose that
we have the Zaleski closure of the
palette permanent contained in this is
key closure the determinant the orbit of
the determinant so inside this place vm
so then we have subjective maps so we
can look at regular functions on these
two orbits so this will be subject to
the same from the other one solid that's
always true subject a nap but a closure
and now if you have the inclusion of the
the map factors if you have the
inclusion we get this extra map
ok because restrict when we straight
from here to here you can just respect
from here to here then to hear that's
the whole point you feel sorry and
subjective very important ok so that's
the picture and then so as I said before
what we will you understand is the not
the obit closure you don't know what
happens when we take the closure but we
still have the orbit and when we have a
function on the closure we can restrict
it to the orbit itself
and this maps so we could hope that
these maps are good approximations and
what we can say a pretty array is that
these maps are injected because this is
an open subset of the closures and
function which vanishes lupin subset it
is zero everywhere so we have injected a
blanket so the strategy is roughly this
if we we have this inclusion then we're
going to have this subject to nap and we
could and we will try to get some
consequences from the fact that we
understand precisely these mr. spaces I
will discover these spaces my second
okay so maybe I can
so maybe added more formulas and suppose
that so what do we know so G remember
this is the in your group in a square
plus 1 variables so it is a group with a
representation theory is well very well
known representation theory so it's part
of a family of groups that we have more
or less like finite groups
it's like yes there is a family of a
groups called addictive groups that
include the Defiant ones than the
general in your groups and
representation Theresa is say easy to to
describe so there are so maybe I sure
that I don't know scare for everybody
some but representation representation
of G is just a vector space over you and
which do acts in some way which means
that there is a morphism from G to the
set of linear transformation of W ok so
you can realize your group by n matrices
acting on this place w and one of the
point is to will try to understand how
you can do that up to isomorphism so
there is a notion of irreducible
representation
so that's essentially so if you think in
terms of mattresses and said that you
cannot reduce the mattresses in some way
that would give a block of zero so there
is no subspace that there is no subspace
preserved by G so the basic
representations are really those which
are irreducible and these are scattered
groups finite groups or general linear
group is this very nice property that
every representation is a direct son of
irreducible
if you want to understand representation
you have just to understand is
irreducible representations and then
there is a general theory they are
encoded by some community oriole data
let's forget it so for fraudulent
Christian explained this in some detail
but let's forget it for for wine so what
we can simply observe that this kind of
a since we have here an obit closure so
there is this group action on the
variety so we have an induced action on
the functions on this variety and so
this is this is a representation of the
group G but infinite dimensional that's
done finitely generated so we can
decompose it into irreducible
representations
so we know that there is some
decomposition okay nap really decomposed
so the space of functions and the obit
closure as a G representation so so can
again we take this representation and we
split it into irreducible representation
presentations reducible representations
are encoded by a combinatorial data and
so we can just look at each irreducible
representation and and see how many
times it appears in in this
representation so we the multiplicity so
maybe the composition sum over all the
irreducible representations of some TV
and there is some multiplicity ok
negative integer we have this and the
same for the obit closure of the padded
permanent priori we have some
decomposition sorry
I will tell you about some some finite
generation about this planet and okay we
can give you a band in the second so we
are the same kind of decompositions for
the permanent
ok and now wait we have this map which
might be subjective and follows from
mothers of general results on gross
using shows lame up doesn't know that
each this map we sent each irreducible
representation either 20 or the same
irreducible representation ok so if we
have a subject in app like this it must
be subjective on each of this factor ok
so
so we can have abstractions to
subjectivity when the multiplicity here
is bigger than the multiplicity here
this happens for sure the map room we
cannot have a subject in my practice so
abstraction to the existence of 20 snap
squared star can you find some
irreducible presentation W such that the
multiplicity coming from the determinant
is smaller than the multiplicity coming
from the pad per minute
if we can show that is the w again it
cannot be a subject in that like that
and so maybe a strong obstruction simply
suggested bike guitar let's be
optimistic and can we find some W such
that its multiplicity zero and the other
one is positive
which is more to mystic but may be so
nice or in some sense because well this
multiplicities are difficult to compute
but hopefully you can find some criteria
that ensure that they they will vanish
so let that the strategy can you find
some basic strategy can we find some
representations for which this
difference in the multiplicities
redundant not to be subjective and so
the a bit closer to be one of the obit
Flores to be continued
any question for the tournament AP
government for permanent end of abusive
share with orbital allow for such as
doing publicity here is bigger than the
pc here is not nothing that there is a
select amount or a hurry before the bat
pappas objective if there is a
subjective of my maybe stuff that yeah i
mean i can bring my for that map
but what what is really nice is that
time why did you exclude the possibility
to this prominent inside yo bit closer
and now we have something positive to do
to construct some representation and
control the multiplicities and ensure
that is for you to discredit so we've
done two positive problem in five
obstructions okay so we have to control
this multiplicity so and again what I
would like to do is use the fact that we
control this which is better than we
control this so the point being that so
GG dat n so I said it is an obit ok so
just apply the group to a point so there
is there is a part of the group there is
a subgroup which does not affect the
point there is a stabilizer we have a
map like this fish
so H stabilizer ok so it's care what it
is it's a group of elements for which
nothing happens you don't don't change
and then you have a let the colonel of
this of this morphism so that in fact
you can see is ova just as a quotient of
G by disapprove H the effective Thank
You Tube that n is simply to kill this
stabilization so suppose that H equal
one so if we look at the we are just you
just have the video bit could be as a
morphic to adjust the group G and then
we know that what this is collette as I
told you these groups and this kind of
group behave very much like finite
groups under sin yesterday that for
finite groups there is this one on
decomposition of the regular
representation has a product of matrix
and algebra and this is also what what
happens in this case so this is the
well-known result due to prettify that
this is the direct sum over the
irreducible representations of and the
morphisms ok so now we have infinitely
many matrix algebra but still the result
is true in general
okay we're trying we write as a sum of W
tensor w dual density ok and so notice
we have you have to your direct tensor
product of representations of G so G
appears twice because there is a
connection of G cross gene ok when you
have a function of a function on g you
can modify it in two different ways by
buying the group either on the left or
the right by GG prime F get function
which an X would be F of minus one x j
XG point minus 1 so the group can act
either on the left on the white and it's
not competitive so you have an action of
G Crosse G and one of the G accent first
item and the allergy acts on the other
one
now when you go to the gym LH so of
course when you when you have an appt
function on gmail edge you can pull back
to G to get function on G so we have
something inside this direct sum and in
fact that you body type by H just means
that must be invariant by the left
action per page okay this you just look
at the functions which are invariant ID
right action at H the right action is
here so you get exactly the sum over the
reducible representations of W star is
denoted like it like that the ancient
grains in double ok so we consume short
leg out now there is no more no action
on G anymore here and on the right it's
just just means that not give reducible
irreducible representation w star
appears with multiplicity equal to the
dimension of this wh
so where are some control is
so then the question in hi how do we
pass to deorbit to the closure because
you have so again we have them when this
to embed ask you can be deadly for the
orbit of the determinant of the padded
permanent go as well and so I can we
compare the regular functions on these
two varieties so there's this issue that
i mentioned some time ago that is this
this is a closed algebraic subset of the
space and unity by VM so I have a
subjective map I can represent any
regular function here by some polynomial
but this is not true anymore for this
put your bit ok this is not exactly
closed
she's never really close because you
have a particular in GG we called G is
the general linear group so you have the
home vertices you can just apply on
matrices to put it again any point 200
is not in the this place okay so so we
don't know it will not be true in
general that regular functions here can
be represented by polynomials so we can
try to weatherproof this problem coming
in century with from the video
multi-season so we can try to get rid of
them by looking not at the GL but sl3
stupid SL we will kill essentially all
the odyssey so let's equal G prime the
group is cell n square plus 1 and inside
this we have the which will be the jeep
rag orbit the determinant of the paddock
communities sorry scaling case came so
we still have some way to scale but if I
think any possibilities quatre sweetie
we don't no longer have this problem
that 0 will be craving the closure we
could be that some well no hope so H
prime is the intersection of h raise
children ok so the question is is this
one those key code
okay because if it is a risky close then
we can we have some control on this and
this is this this and this our role is
the same up two scallops we can compare
them so the good news our debt so the g
prime orbits of either the determinant
of the permanent are closed so we're in
good shape the bad news is that the jeep
arm of it we take the padded permanent
it's not closed
so we have to work and how they're in
this case let's say no so let's consider
the determinants and see what can we can
deduce from the [ __ ] is closed n so if
you don't tell if you don't multiply by
the linear from your business closed
some reason wait well there is a there
is a classical Tarun by camp data when
when just on diabetes is not closed this
is because much me because there is some
preferred space in general when you take
a point in a space and the group acting
it's the obit is not close there must be
some some special subspace okay which is
privileged by just privileged by your
own I have another question so firm and
the editor it might be in the closure of
the G orbiter yet but not in the closure
of the cheap I'm morbid this it's a
smaller / y and white white why would
this be okay study
that's an engine problem okay that's a
smaller set the house would serve this
bedding said you can just look away from
by see your friend you could just scale
it right in there ok so the
representation it was no different
okay I'm so that's so further
determinant the determinant and so on yo
[ __ ] is closed the G prime H brunch and
so we have a again you have this
which will be subjective and the other
one gigabit closure of geometry or
service
remember to mention the situation of the
hyperbola now we'll add I need to be G
prime number h1 which is scary when you
take the corner ready at the village
which is guh and it's not already closed
for plain- be 2 x's that's the typical
so the product thing to mention is that
so here this is the space of polynomials
Tory's ready at the degree and since
here we have a code which is also graded
by the degree it's not ready this one is
not a cone anymore so there is love
ready
instead what we can do is we have also a
restriction that since this is obviously
a subset of here which is subjective
remember that this we understand very
well this is what you try to understand
so what so we have the subjectivity is a
gentle and now we can restrict through
each degree restricted agreed upon young
girls
okay so what does that then we have a
point number of degrees II suppose we
had some English prison of the original
vanish patches here so we have two
polynomial coma for this brandon
vanishes on it since it's homogeneous to
vanish every way this map is infecting
check
the time we have good control of this
man the subjectivity and intrinsically
tht consequences yet regarding the
formula given by the pit / and
composition by 2 g prime is that P & G
crime module irreducible you cry module
w prepares
and what we want to understand
you can only live space of invariance
sorry let's also like this we don't have
a good control about this is because we
have a recital subjective that you can
have good lift on your inducible g prime
module to different degrees this group
verify the multiplicities in some money
or you don't understand the face we have
a criteria to decide whether they're not
just easy role or not and you want to
sell obstruction this is an important
issue
so this is actually doing programming
fine so again are obstructions so still
we have this issue that forgetting that
time you'll get the credit determinant
is not closed it's not too far from the
info at least we understand why it is
not closed it's an information from this
that's technically want to talk about
that so so we have to understand out the
invariance to understand h/h product
variants of the determinants of the
pregnant
and the last night's fact is that this
so we understand this group pretty well
it's in their homework so the exercises
stabilizer
okay so is a diamond there are two ways
to transform the mattress in a way to
preserve the determinism x 2 matrices on
the right with that right into the
determinant Oakland won the same as a
transpose X so you set up the stabilizer
in this case edge is giant cross your
hand followed by zitu
so next group the provenance
it's been working
sorry it's better right SL cross us out
but right it's somewhere between the two
yeah yeah well if you look at the image
it's really smaller than even SL across
the cell but it's safer to write that's
worth anything
commencing just
hi
before the permanent to get some
product of two groups which are
guaranteed by predictions and then
metrics permutation matrices with a so
when you try to or is really striking is
that when you try to understand about
the cities so this when you cut
abstraction we need to decide whether
you have these kind of invariance for
the terminals so the existence of
obstructions is related to very old
mathematics we have two symmetrically
there's another diagonal matrices but
you also have a tourist yeah i oughtta
physique to that the report was confused
I thinking TM Taurus monomial next and
over thursday z2 permutation matrices
with conditions hanging from ok register
some fish it's related to presentation
of some measure groups
something earlier Tessa netting you and
in the end at some point you need to
understand presentations of symmetrical
with the clinical rotations can be zero
so on special connect Oak Ridge
recognitions mean big the visitors you
get down and pick two presentations of
the metal groups by Sigma reducible
representations and I said to take
dancer products so please again as some
other representations of the group again
miss about the pc just collecting
petitions and I mean need to be several
certain disconnected a zero so again
it's
great because we use clinical conditions
i've been studied for four years lots of
results in them that is that what we
would need to other studies is to be
still much are rich ppl one day about
discussions this matter
where you can show instructions because
I didn't lie in that sense of you know
we do have some examples I'm going to
determine for a minute but other Paula
meals
naturally
travel around like you operate them yes
which is really interesting that there's
ISA projects are different problems not
that's that's it for this product or on
the productivity so much expectations
it's a working device and stretching in
this very house tube and a benefit event
from the church limitations because each
need and that is a very like that that's
also sort of a heart problem I mean it
seems like there should be easier things
yeah so about preferably the Ho Chi Minh
and this do them just get so fun for
this problem to have an explicit easier
problem in mind like just take like the
x1's the d + XM this or d
consider you know I find any changes of
productions of that phone you can show
that like that many many many
and like that's a very easy thing to
show
if you know and so it's sort of like you
can imagine you know promoting that go
around there's a sort of ideal a
dimension of some partial derivative
space larger the determinant for
permanent but it's small midi sort of
thing that gives you an explicit you
know separation hope show me you being
theory to say that both after one think
the problem is a group the group for
that is is so small that it's going to
be hard to do it but one thing that sort
of makes this or more tractable
especially to the determinant is the
group is very very large so it's harder
to come in very sorry we should be
simply this increase of the determined
yes so so it makes it easier to have
invariance because the group is lauded
for is the smaller group right right I
said it the other way around view too
many environments as someone to remote
salon business users should you don't
have it hurts under your group your
group so you mean the power some
excellent
I think that's a very good test case but
even reverse our students really it's
not interested not easy to analyze
first time have shown but the terminals
ferment will be completed by determinant
of silence go over to yes don't be shown
in the sense of obstruction what kind of
solvent it's not it cannot be shown in
like this approach it merits that that
module is not instruction that Civic
ahead could help us recover same results
as an obstruction we virtually results
by these clinical conditions so we need
to control special types of kinetic
repetitions and your nutrition was that
it was very hard to expect some click
agree any codec I coefficients to be
zero seems to be very uncommon and so we
have new hope sex to get on improve that
must exist many clinical issues still
get there if you control these clinical
rotations are especially those that are
especially there is no concrete result
debts in this situation
if you say in which places the these
reductions you do or not tight enough so
you do with serious introductions if you
make a problem Frank you have the
initial problem like asking whether
could you say we're ready to move large
gaps you know essays well essentially we
gotta solve the original problem with
this approach this question is more
difficult than the original question it
could be it's a stronger conjunction yes
from projection our standard I'm really
the way the way we what would really say
that the permanent in the Korean
entertainment tie between the subjective
map to reduction use as for obstructions
they are just memory construction coming
from multiplicities first rejection
which which is that cannot have is
subjective up and the Motor City's
benefit when you what is be good then
was not Justin to be 0 these are didn't
mean to elections but really the fact
that these colleges in dinuba closures
mean equivalent to the existence in this
together so then there is another point
which is that the closure is not exactly
what we want
if there are no further questions and I
suggest that
okay so their closeness of these orbits
is a simple double berth not important
yes I just kept score Clary nice cousins
are you miss Gilbert number you just
need to show the Tenderfoot that's a
happy customer so you don't go there
today we'll be exploring